a start
um if there is any fires today i'm not
expecting one and if you like those
let's just make sure to the car park
please um
number one apologies kirsten
um we've had apologies from janet
williams and councillor newton has sent
his apologies and captain up hardy
thank you
um and now we'll go on title number two
which is minutes of the previous meeting
i'll take them page by page i'll go by
the numbers at the bottom of the page
and page three
page four
page five
page six
page seven
page eight
thank you
any abstentions
um
item number three public contributions
can i just ask why we are not recording
the import meeting we have with north
devon on the thesis because it's the
statutory responsibility discoveries
we did meet that we were in for it can
we record that i'm going to record those
at the next meeting
because there's only just been published
so we'll give people a chance to read
them and then there will be no minutes
because there was no meeting because the
meetings
there's
is okay public participation no public
participation today
so then we're going to go on to number
four which is the action list
um 79 which is for me um just to
keep my eye out for ongoing funding and
forward to afford them to lots of people
actually not just these listed here
um
80 to contact
89 is complete
89 council lever to send information
about how that's been done
89
still recommendations to cnr
and a request to take the full council
budgets set in that's not going to
happen just yet we're not at that
meeting aren't we
was the budget setting
or it's november yeah so it's been added
to the cnr oh it's been okay
it's been added to the cnr agenda
um council of pennington democratic
services that's been done the letter was
certain time ago
um
91 a joint meeting to be arranged all
over the page
um that's on the cards for january
but we will just chat in before the
meeting we've actually got cab that are
available in january
and that meeting's actually a six
o'clock meeting so we may put the health
board one on to the two o'clock meeting
which is in march it's still it's not
set in stone so we'll
remain flexible on that
okay number 91 that's not been addressed
yet that's a bit further off
so that maybe i'll come into april now
that's ongoing
any
questions the action list
um number five declarations of interest
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interest when the item is
considered
number six we don't have any part two so
we should be very straightforward
and um number seven urgent matters
brought forward mission of the chair now
i've got two items
here one from myself and one from
councillor cheryl
hunkin
i don't know if you've all seen this
have you got it like a day
it's a survey that has been released
by the fire brigade by the chief fire
officer
it's sort of a
risk assessment management plan in it
it's a consultation um it's an online
document that you can log on to and
we're encouraging everybody to try and
fill it in um the actual question page
is actually quite short and quite simple
i strongly agree or
strongly disagree um and all of the text
that you need to read and need to
understand is actually highlighted in
the blue hyperlinks and when you click
onto them you will find that it's
actually quite a lengthy document
i was
quite least how short it was and then i
actually clicked on them and there's
there's quite quite a bit of reading
there to have an understanding of the um
potential document that you're
answering the questions on
so
if anybody can spare the time to do that
it's going to be a valuable piece of
information that goes back to the fire
service
okay thank you
um
council hosting
chairman i know i'm not a member
quite a lengthy document
and i noticed that they do refer to the
closure
of certain fire stations but it
doesn't say anything about what we
fought against
during lockdown with the proposed
closure
of upper door and
but there are
references to efficiencies
and effectiveness of locations and i
just wonder if
you know we need to be aware that
or should we be asking questions as to
whether this is still on the planet and
on their longer term vision for
efficiency and cost savings
um for us because that would be again
something we would need to be very aware
would you do that would you like us to
ask questions
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah um i think it's probably
foreign but there's a bit of a crossover
i was wondering what the process is for
registering assets of community values
um when that's online and i think we'll
see go back to 2013
[Music]
it needs updating so that's currently
something that's being worked on at the
label between property and legal but if
somebody wants to make a registration
it'll go to tom phillips and property
and they're making this estimate but we
do need to
have a clear process but
legislation how that process works and
the factors that have to be taken into
account so it's it's legislation based
effectively
because there was um
online that said something about in
liaison with board members
making the decision no because we don't
have much
legal room that's set out in the
legislation as to when we can and when
we can't listen if we oblige you we then
put it on our
asset community register
which is then published on our website
but you're right in terms of the process
isn't clear to the public at the moment
[Music]
or is that that's the legislation
that sets that out
yeah something we can't um deal with
unfortunately
thank you
okay um now we're gonna go to number
eight which is uh uh to receive a report
on the update of the play strategy um
i've not met you before my name's joe
finally
[Music]
is as well yeah sure um simply i'm
adrian avery the community engagement
officer um for torridge
um i've not involved as a project
officer it's for me
to go out into our communities and do as
best we can to establish any projects
that communities are considering how we
can try and move them forward um
whether they're where their options move
forward or not or how we can try and if
they need funding if i can help funding
those sorts of things a lot of my work
has been around sport and leisure and
things like active travel play area
strategy or help all sorts of health and
well-being forums i kind of try and try
and sit on so that's
part of my roles and
like dipping it out of all sorts of
things so so that's me i don't know
[Music]
okay well yeah thank you we known each
other for quite a while in various
different roles
[Music]
independent men were not elected
yeah councilman christina
northern phil pennington monthly and fox
no play areas
whatsoever and we uh maintain our own
and put our own hands in our own pockets
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
yeah thank you
thank you okay um it's good it's good
thanks for um thanks for calling this um
i do really i'll give a brief update
i'll put some um
slightly updated printouts on your
on the tables and from what was sent out
before i think from i'm sure
it's a very slight amendment but they're
not a great deal um we'll talk about
that in a little bit um so our player
strategy was approved in summer but this
year we it was a bit of a wrangle around
around the finances which um
almost as long ago
but since then um as part of our
strategy we aim to set up a working
group
which we've done
we've recognised that it's clearly
important our play areas are
attempting to be as good a condition as
possible for the obvious usage for our
families and our visitors especially
after
the long wait from government where
is worse or important than the more
places that families could get to
um since then yes like so we set this
working group that consists of
our contract manager
um two or three members from the estates
team that work on the ground and go out
and do the
very regular site visits to the play
areas and do all the management of
equipment and work with our maintenance
team as well
we meet
every two months and we serve so that
regular meeting happens every two months
to discuss solely our play areas and
and the conditions and how we move
forward
and
we will on we will be working with um
richard hayes on going as well and he's
going to be coming to our next meeting
who
they will be picking up our operations
services as well so we're linking in
quite closely together on them uh we our
our conversations this week have been
around although we haven't been our
conversation this week i've been around
making sure that we have our conditioned
survey the one that was part of the play
area strategy originally which is what
we were working for that was done back
in 2019
that's going to be updated from our team
before april 1st when our services got
back in hatch
since may we've made some some
[Music]
some improvements of some of our sites
um hopefully bringing up some of the um
some of the levels uh we would have in
line with our target to meet all areas
to be our aspirations to be good
standard by january 2023 and we've made
some fairly decent strives towards that
um
we've as a part of that we've considered
some of the spaces that were very much
put in as
from our housing developers which are
possibly so small that we can barely be
recognized as a
play area some would say so we've
considered them as well which we may
may or may not hopefully possibly
be considered social spaces going
forward um we will see where we work
with them
that will give us a low maintenance
option
but also we're always considering our
finances but also we recognize that
social spaces are also just as important
as play areas sometimes so um we can
discuss that a little bit further
we recognize that
we do get
we do get some members of the public um
asking questions about our player is so
we also recognize that we need to
make sure that this is currently not on
the on our website we will make sure
that is in its current state so that
people can are well aware that it's
there and can be read um from there
um and yeah and that's that's really
that's really where we're at it's just
really a point that we are you know i
feel that we have made some good
improvements but um
we do also recognize it isn't a vast
ongoing project
um so we're just hoping for multiple
questions and comments ready
can i ask
them
yeah and the schedule we've got here
adrian is this the full extent of all
the play areas in tight and torridge
yes i haven't thought that but okay but
so really my question is why isn't west
potomac play area on there
sorry those that is not the full extent
of every player yeah their tourism
council's playing okay so i'm quite new
here i wasn't sure that's all right no
sorry i wasn't i haven't got i was
hoping that so that's what that's
tourist
player is there will be lots of others
around that encourages his own
you know and and that they maintain and
look after thank you okay
um
just that um
you mentioned westbrook
um we have the park that's been
transferred to
um
but we also have a play area that
um torridge are responsible for on the
ground
which is in sorry state
and has been reported several times for
you know rusty
uh
playing equipment
and
he's still in charges
here so it's nothing to do with
the westwood haircut which is a
completely separate entity yeah so i
think perhaps that's what just
was referring to
oh sorry
okay
i actually haven't been talking about
those i've been
[Music]
[Music]
that recently yes okay so hopefully then
we meet every two months so in december
in december 16th
meeting hopefully
is
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
we have some very sharp rusty metal
edges
and is that just a village where you you
think that'll be out for me
okay
we put that on our action list
that's right
and then we can chase it up keep an eye
on it
okay thank you thank you
councillor
yeah i agree i was surprised when i read
it said good against village green and
the two above benson drive and hanson
park
[Music]
but amended by themselves so yeah
absolutely with that girl yeah and the
other thing is
against the lord is keep keep keep keep
keep and yet we've discussed before
possibly offering play areas to parish
and town councils
where's that in the thinking
so that is that is our thinking what
we're trying to do at the minute is
to recognize
you know some of these various classes
key i think this i'm trying to recognize
where they are at distance compared to
other play areas sometimes as well um we
are we have spoken to to a couple of
parishes i.e we went to
uh when we go to shevia not not too long
ago
they there certainly that's not one they
would like to take over at this stage
but also those competitions are all
going around so they wouldn't want to
take it in if there's a lot of work to
do we recognize that places wouldn't
want to take them on in a poor condition
so they'd have to be brought up to to a
certain degree at a certain level if
they wouldn't do that
even even if we did do that i think
particularly that council would still
not want to
want to take it on so those
conversations are taking place with some
parishes but i think also that
we like we recognize that you know there
are certain ones that most of the
probably that we would still like to
keep in hand it's really those ones
recognizing that really
if we if we're not able to we haven't
got to to some of
um i wiggly we'll add those discussions
around what they would like to and those
are generally around the development the
housing development play areas so they
can be often tricky to
consider to upload to local parishes if
you like as well especially if they've
spent money on other areas they might
have in their their own site so we are
certainly
having those conversations um with
certain areas but um we recognize that
there's probably a bit of work to do
before that before really
getting involved with too heavy in those
conversations i would say
well i see geneva court and benefits
being
it requires improvement and handles
against that i think that that's just
that's really a question mark for us
in terms of handover those decisions
have not been made as to yes they
definitely want to hand them over i
think this the key aspect for us is to
do the work first on them if it requires
improvement we need to get it to that
that better level first
and the same with intolerant you've got
cars from clothes and bathroom
yeah since that since that hand over
certainly next to path fields
we recognize that yes it's in a good
condition but
there's there's minimal
equipment in there and the other thing
we're taking consideration is where they
are as part of the town so
some of the conversations we have is
actually
do they need to be does that need to be
added to
as a play area or like field is quite a
large space with minimal play area but
it could probably be used a bit more
recreational but the more lived invite
older generation that section of the
town as an example so wouldn't get used
as
as a play area so
yes if they would if they wanted to
consider
torrington town council wanted to
consider taking that one to say um i
would say it's unlikely at this stage
but because there's minimal
um equipment in there it's quite a low
cost
and cars very close you've got legal
investigation
that's i think it's next to us next to a
property i think they're encroaching on
the
um onto the play area a little bit i
think they're trying to do some work in
there and they're um
they've i think they've started to creep
into close to the play area so there are
discussions with our state's team around
that
and i'll leave you in peace after this
go back to benson drive and it says
maintenance obligations from the
investigation
that's one we've recognized that that
we've been um
paying for our maintenance worked on it
but we're not there's there's
investigations going on to actually the
ownership of the site you know where it
works yeah we don't own it
yeah that's right so we've been
maintaining
an area that is empowered to maintain so
you're right it's still in the
developers ownership
but they've offered it throughout the
tournament more than that
i'm not sure if they have i i think they
were obviously pleased with the
situation as it was in that they owned
it and we were maintaining it and it
came up when the
i think it's come up as part of
richard's bringing the grounds
maintenance in place because he's been
doing assessments of all the areas of
what we do and don't know so richard
quite rightly plugged it up and when the
legal team have looked into it it's not
ours so
um
i'm not sure what we're going to be
doing with it if we're going to take it
on um but we'll obviously stop
maintaining it
it's not ours too
[Music]
[Music]
our state of play once
um the ownership does come to an end i
know there's a
one in torrington as well at the minute
i think um
drive i think that potentially that's
coming to an end of their ownership and
and it's a conversation of you know how
does that how does that work moving
forward who takes responsibility for
that
how can it work so those are definitely
conversations thank you i've got a few
things if i may but the first one is and
you'll probably remember that
at full council it went to full council
from this committee about issues about
whether there should be a budget
specifically for um playground
maintenance and the decision was made
that there shouldn't be
so my question is when
when the improvements that have been
made and things being repaired like the
zipwhile at denver park and the zip wire
etc which is great that they've been
paid but
how where has that money come from and
hasn't been issues getting older
i think so i think what we've what we've
done and i think we've amended in the
strategy
is that it was recognized certainly from
our working group that those bits of
maintenance and if they if
if it's broken it needs to be fixed as
maintenance it's not replacing the new
it's not replacing an additional item so
therefore it comes down to maintenance
budget and not the capital cosmetics so
in our eyes it's something great needs
to be placed in you know we're not
replacing a whole new unit it's it's
part of the zip wire that is fixing
that's maintenance and it comes out of
our maintenance budget therefore it gets
done pretty quickly and that's what
we've been able to manage to move on
with these bits right okay that's great
um did um
did anything come back to you about
climbed a road
that's internal
as something to do with the qbr it came
up that um
um
about
the parks and i mentioned clyde and road
against the water and
um somebody said it came back i think
from you that clydedon road wasn't um
at orange park but um
jude said that it was it definitely was
a torridge park and it is torridge land
yeah the play equipment was removed was
unique it was unsafe in something like
2018.
so it's kind of what's the situation now
and
local residents are getting anxious
because
is there going to be play equipment
backing play equipment doesn't go back
that's fine if it's going to be
maintained as a green area for
recreational use but they could do with
knowing yes so it's kind of what's the
situation with somewhere like that the
latter isn't exactly it and why
electrically actually quick conversation
yesterday with property i didn't i
didn't email it back
so yes that is the case the equipment go
into poor condition again i don't know
anything there but
the um yeah we just got road sights had
had section 106 money pumped into it to
improve that site therefore the
equipment was taken away from the
clinton road and and it's it's been left
as an open recreational space and that's
how it's intended to stay
right okay so it's not going to be a
player because it's right next door to
the bigger area of albuquerque right
okay okay but local residents can be
assured that it will stay as a green
area for
i believe so yes that's my understanding
i don't know if there's any
future developments around that site
have no idea only that it's
as it is as a recreational space okay
because they can walk through it i
believe i don't know if they think they
can walk from
through there and actually makes its way
down through that housing development
country towards downtown
and it gives a nice link between the two
so so yeah
as far as i'm aware it's open
recreational space and it's one of those
i'm sorry
i think is that right
just to say that old town park's been
mentioned to me
um it's on here it's required
improvement so we do the gates need and
and just that's just a reminder that
local residents have said
it needs to be fixed and there's a piece
of equipment there as well so old town
park has been yeah
have you seen them turn apart in the
last couple weeks no has to be done well
no there are ongoing they've made some
nice improvements with our little green
town project our our
gardening project and then they've got
some nice planters and there's some new
victories
[Music]
there's two gate areas in old town one
that wasn't working and one that's not
there it's deemed that one doesn't need
replacing but the one does need to fit
it might be the residents
want that gate replacing because
in theory although they may or may not
i'll bring this conversation around dog
walking yeah yeah they should go to
leads or shouldn't we ever get into the
bay area and it's actually i think it's
signed in there that dogs should be on a
lead so therefore you shouldn't need the
gate on the play area but the other one
there is one the other side which has
been fixed
i think it's just getting the message
through to people about the gate issue
because some parents would feel that
that park if the gates that they their
children are safe in that park but
obviously there's a view now that don't
things don't need to be gated unless
they're literally opening onto a road
and maybe people don't
yeah right yeah that's communication
yeah that's right unless unless it runs
out onto a road
which
they would have to get through another
gate in the old town park to get through
onto the main road so it's quite well
built up there but i understand the uh i
don't understand the concern okay and i
think there's a piece of equipment there
as well that one needs to replace that
is being replaced lovely um victoria
park just quick update on that what's
the situation there yeah so victoria
park we have a community group set up um
it is a slow process
with them at the minute right um they
have started applying funding um they
haven't done the same day
i'm working with them um to do the
community engagement work there's not
enough of that has been done as yet so
when they're applying for some funding
i.e rotary club they want to know
specifics on ins and outs of what's
going in
potentially
um there is half a thought that actually
from the community group of
would it be better or something like a
big bought section can we replace some
of the items that were there try and
make it a little bit more cost effective
maybe what was there it's kind of not
really my aspirations i want that to be
a new site but we will um we're having
those conversations we're actually
having that site
um prosper inspected next week uh the
billy bought section in fact the whole
the whole area so that'll give us a
really good understanding of what can
stay and what you know
so community group is set up they are
starting to apply for funds there is a
an online
um crowdfunding page which uh
there's contributions from um various
groups which trust
so as well so there's a bit of money in
the pot
but there's a lot more needed so it is
ongoing we have aspirations to try to
get that done by the spring
they're quite i know because that was
the day in the play strategy that was
the day yeah yeah so
if we get if we can raise some money in
time
my last one is really just an
observation that
it's about how the criteria are put
together for
assessing something that's good i know
i know we want it to be safe that's the
most important thing that would be safe
but there's a there's a difference
between being something being safe and
mended or something being inspiring for
young people to play and once
everything's mended it would be lovely
if we could take it that step further to
making it inspirational
thank you i think
she doesn't want that's fine
[Music]
truly
and the things that actually need to be
replaced two different projects
maintenance
and being a place to bring bring the
whole play inventory up to a standard
you'd be having
is that the next stage your members
really do need to have
the nasty news in the way yeah because
it's bad
and effective
yeah so you're right so two sections for
that the there is um there's work going
on in a minute from the estate team
about pricing up the safety surfacing
that was something that was raised a
moment ago and that is
probably outside of outside the
equipment our biggest concern might be a
quite big expense but again
potentially maintenance which hopefully
we might have got
um and that is that's fairly well spread
across the board most of our sites are
struggling with safety servicing
because they hold most of the old sort
of brilliant services which kind of gaps
in between them whereas new they would
just go right over the top of the rubber
and it would just be spread right over
the top of their own room so that is
ongoing now
that's our current situation that's
being priced up
but in terms of the actual items
required that's going to be in the
conditional survey that are taking ready
for the first of april so that will
recognize what needs what our items
specifically need putting in and and
therefore
we'll have that crossover
langford's last question about the
assessment period or the assessment of
you know up from
home is done
how is it done because i am a little bit
concerned when i see good for the
green at western when i hear the two
questionable was saying they disagree
with the assessment so can you give us a
background of who makes this assessment
and and then where we can supposedly
challenge that when we do this wrong
yeah absolutely absolutely right so that
is done by by myself with the estates
team currently
we our work is done by our by our
maintenance team
but again you're absolutely right to ask
who makes that assessment so on on
monday i'm meeting with the the ross
eldon safety team at victorian park and
we're hoping to get a bit more guidance
from them when we have we feel that
there should definitely be the annual
inspection on all our sites so certainly
in terms of the health and safety point
of view that
they are the experts if you like um
although our maintenance team are
trained um attention to a roster to
whatever qualifications they've got so
they are guiding us currently which we
go by for all health and safety but
actually there's nothing
really that suggests
what is
we're going by
this um which tivoli wrote up in 2019
and we're just trying to sort of work
alongside comparing them all to each
other
making these recommendations
um that's there's been improvement now
so who is making that record is that
roster no making them
no not that no it's us as steven
yeah
then i'm just a little bit nervous of
what's happening i would like to make a
recommendation that we either have some
member involvement
or an independent
view
of an assessment because should a child
become injured and there was a
grandchild of one of my residents that
broke their arm in victoria's park
and i want to make sure that if there is
any incident that does happen we have
been independent and fully checked
ourselves from this point of
view okay
and so i i would like to make that a
recommendation that we have some form of
independence on the assessment process
and i would like to talk for a second if
that could be a recommendation if
anybody is interested in doing that
so that's that's good so that's what
prosper will be doing with victoria park
as an independent on monday okay that's
what they're that's where we like to see
that more on our site is rosberg
independent of pvc yes sorry
that's done by a maintenance team their
qualifications we're creating them on an
aspirational level of whether we think
that's good for thanksgiving but that
gives me a little bit of confidence if
roster is independent and they will come
back with with an independent report
then and they will come back with an
independent report on each of the sites
so they will do that for victoria park
alone on
monday right which is
i think 500 pounds for just victoria
park right and and then what we would
like ideally for everyone to have that i
think that only has been done once a
year
to have that assessment helping save the
assessment
okay so that report will come back to
this committee at some point in the
future it can do yeah absolutely yeah so
we want to we're going to put that
conditional certainly in place for all
our sites which is going to be done by
our team in terms of what equipment it's
got and what it hasn't got by april so
alongside that we'd like to see a lot of
report for all our sites independently i
think stacy would like to come back
let's just get a writing clarification
enhanced by pennington and just to
provide assistance but currently um we
outsource this work so it's within our
grounds maintenance contract and tivoli
do our health and safety assessments and
i think as members know
we're in the process of bringing that
in-house richard hayes is doing the
assessments and setting up the
specialists because there's a lot when
we say grounds maintenance um there's a
lot more involved it's tree maintenance
it's even the graveyards that the
digging of the degree so there's a lot
of specialist work so i was just
thinking as you were talking
um whether it be worth while richard
kind of talking me through his plans and
what because that's something it's a big
bit of work that's being worked on now
um
and he's assessing all of that um
and in terms of the assessments and
health and because health and safety for
our patient you know parks and pay areas
that's key
and there's a massive bit of work but i
was thinking if that would put your mind
at rest and perhaps we have richard come
and do an explanation to committee and
he can talk you through
um his plans going forward and where
he's got to thus far with that piece of
work well thank you for that
explanation for guilty thank you very
much for the responses that really helps
the scene um
there's been a lot of work done through
this committee i don't want to lose the
foundation we have in the past and that
has provided the foundation by which we
can move forward
and if we can add that roster report to
it then it gives the outside influence
that i feel was so vital
um that it will come forward
and withdraw my proposition from you if
you've got that independent
[Music]
[Music]
cnr there was 771 000 allocated from the
surplus of 2021 to a leisure fund
and you talked about the maintenance
budget now we caught that
maintenance budget issue in to full
council because they didn't want the
maintenance budget that our officers
didn't know about this budget
and it does beg the question of it do we
have access to that ledger fund do i
understand it wasn't solely for the
swimming pools it was for leisure
facilities as well um and but it feels
like we you know you've got to go
begging to to to officers um to get
access to funds where funds are needed
because we don't have a dedicated uh
maintenance funding what about the
friendly report that we had last year i
think it was about 71 000 pounds a year
we were spending on average i think it
was a six-year period uh previous to
2020. um i just wondered if we were
keeping
[Music]
my specialist subject at all um in terms
of the maintenance budget there is a
maintenance project budget for property
and i i think and the previous
discussions centered around ring fencing
it specifically for play parks and areas
and i think our head of finance david h
at that stage said look
you know it's just putting on a
different budget line the money's there
so we we always have a maintenance
budget it's just not particularly
allocated to parks and play areas but if
something needed doing within one of our
parks or play areas it would come from
that budget
but you know again it's a fixed amount
you know we've only got a certain
certain amount of money which is why we
did the play strategy so we could really
focus on
um the areas that we were retaining and
make them the best that we possibly
could but you know there's there's no
doubt about it
you know the budgets are always only
ever going to stretch so far um in terms
of leisure that's an entirely separate
um thing mata
that a report is coming forward to full
council on the
13th of december for members to consider
there
and in terms of budgets as a whole we're
just starting our budget setting process
cycle and we've got a capital pimp day
coming up at kensdowne not sure if it's
next week or the week after so all
members can feed into that and that will
start the process of our budget setting
for next year
i think that was your questions
i'm not sure if i left it
about the you know the
debate we had about making this budget
because there was an issue uh a feeling
then that that um
it wasn't a a definite but if you know
there's a definite budget for a pacific
area you know whether you're overspent
or you're under spending you have to
keep within that budget whereas i feel
play parks have gone into situation oh
we've got the situation have you got the
money in the kitty and you know it's
almost like um we need to do the
assessment
and we need to record if we can't meet
the need if there is something there and
when we're over budget we need you know
to report that but where we are at the
moment it seems like oh yeah we need
that have we got the money um and it's
the back of the city job
local authority-wise if you follow the
logic is there the money about so um
that's where the budget argue came from
yeah i think there's an acceptance that
we can't just replace all equipment in
all parts
um you know but replacing equipment and
like you say the day-to-day repairs are
are separate and come from so if there
was something dangerous in a play park
we do have a maintenance budget that we
could go with and repair but you know
things are you know limited um and
that's where the play strategy came
through because i think there was a
recognition that we couldn't do
everything all the time um and to start
having discussions with community groups
and parish and talent councils regarding
taking over the parks if possible
therefore they're leaving torridge with
the park you know
with the parks and focusing on them and
making as council language said them the
best that they possibly can be within
within reason that's fine and i just
asked a question very quickly
what is social space is that just a
green field
the idea is to
keep it fairly maintenance level but
also um to have big adventures in there
to actually create an environment where
people can come and sit and have a
coffee that was important
for bid for tankers but those lovely
benches down with the games on the farm
before there and uh if you go to social
space perhaps that could be replicated
in the area yeah where is the grains of
benefit by the way the branches of
western homes
on the
social spaces
um is that that's
our buckley grange
they're lovely girls that's what holder
from westwood haven uh yeah sorry
opposite yeah buckley the buckley
laundry area up there um on that that is
literally that's what i talk about these
places being so small i mean it's no
bigger than this little section here
it's got one item in it and we we never
know of anybody that uses it but it's
what i wouldn't class as a of an even
classic as a social couldn't find if i
went to look for them
so
yeah
it took me a while thank you very much
[Music]
and
um
for victoria park um
whether we can support the funding
applications
it's worth less caring for this
community maybe
in support of their aims
i think that'll depend on what the
funder requires not all funders require
letters of support but i think i'd
rightly say and if they do require
elected support we'd quite happily write
one
[Music]
[Music]
but if they are being turned down in
their applications
i don't know you very well adrian
forgive me um i'm happy to look at the
applications and obviously you don't
know me but underneath mine
was mine here's my
actually technical area
and setting
[Music]
squeeze them in
and
cheryl shirley um castle langford and
then councillor
thank you my fancy paul thank you um
just to say that the tables in victoria
park
um it's a bit of a town centre
partnership so it's various bodies come
together and they raise the money for
those tables
with permission of tdc to put them there
but they're also now raising money for a
table tennis table as well an outdoor
table tennis table to try and improve
them so that's where they that came from
just coming back to victoria park the
cool part does worry me
because i
would hate to get to next year and find
there is no improvement having told that
date and i understand
i
understand what sharon has said about
the fundraising in toronto and
everything the thing is you've got other
situations like the park at apple in
appledore the pirate ship that went in
there was you know new equipment a whole
lot of new equipment went in there
beautifully wonderfully you know just
before the day strategy
and i just well i mean because you and
me on this capital day stacy am i right
i know there's money's tied for so many
projects but presumably
if the report comes back really damning
about the
the thought
there might be a case that that meeting
say
we've got to discuss putting some
money
to a project for victory park play area
i mean am i right or not
yeah i mean that should take to feed in
and that's when all the pigs will come
through
um
and decision members will need to make
decisions about what their priorities
are for the next financial year
um so
ideas as to what what members
aspirations are and what they would like
to and it may be that some get put in
some get put out but it that it's
ultimately the start of
our budget setting and the
[Music]
it's not great thank you
thank you thank you castle lover
yeah
it follows on anyway from council
pennington and council landfill to a
point
when we were discussing our play
strategy earlier
at this committee
the big concern was
the two things
equipment that for two
too many years torridges was taken out
of players if it became damaged or
you can't use it it would just take that
and every place
and there was never any budget for
replacing equipment
the maintenance one which we argued long
and hard for
many areas of
uh service intelligence got their own
maintenance budget we felt that there
should be an allocated budget for
maintenance of our play spaces and
equipment
if we replace equipment
then we need an ongoing maintenance
budget and
capital budget really for when that
equipment eventually breaks down it does
need to be placed
so
if we're doing this budget setting
process shortly that will be one thing
that i think a lot of members
have to be made aware but what i would
have liked to see today
is when things are classed as good
upgraded to good night it doesn't
necessarily mean that all the pieces of
equipment that should be there are in
there
all right
[Music]
couple of bits were placed where they
felt they definitely need replacing i.e
old town we know there's a space there
so we know that's going to be [ __ ]
back in and there will be lots of spaces
where there are where there are bits
mixes have not been replaced but that
will come into our condition survey aim
for the first of april so that we know
that we can budget that and that's a bit
that's a bit late for our budget setting
process because what i was going to
suggest is we really need
a cost of replacement equipment now
that's needed so in our play areas now
where pieces of equipment been taken
and not replaced i'd like to see it
listed where they are and how much it
will be to replace them some aren't that
very expensive some of the rockers
aren't that expensive and this council
is looking at
quite a large underspent again this year
and i know everybody wants to grab a
piece of it and for me the number one
project in this case is the new
environments
but behind that for me is playerspace
and play areas they are clear we always
hear about youngsters being given plenty
of opportunity for play and the rest of
it and
not this current council but for many
years before
we've let these players go they've been
put in equipped and then they've gone
down the other one
so we need a capital budget to replace
equipment but i'd like to know
roughly what kind of costs are we
looking at to put them all in order to
put the pieces back in without this
were similar pieces back here
and then when we're looking at setting
budgets we can say right we'll have a
capital budget for replacing equipment
and play areas
well without that information
okay is that something that
it's um 4pm
okay
um potentially yeah if we
we haven't got me into life for that so
we can you know have a chat with our
estates team and linkedin
i think that'll certainly cancel his
mind and have to let his mind at ease
that we have
if we want to slide this
rocky thing you know i don't go to the
parliament yeah
yeah because the condition report in
2019 that adrian
start
that did list all the players and those
are pieces of equipment that were
missing
so it's not hard to look through and
find but if if you need to nip out to
one or two of them say yes you're still
missing yourself and this and pick the
phone up go online and do it in a matter
of a couple of hours online what these
pieces of equipment cost and do it
pretty good and i think when it comes to
um maintaining the equipment adrian has
given a good example of
the zip wires that have been mended they
have come out of the maintenance budget
so that i don't think there's ever going
to be a separate park maintenance budget
there is one big maintenance budget for
whatever needs doing
so
you know if the
broken equipment that needs maintaining
to repair is reported then i think yeah
it can come out of that budget so i
think it's almost the reporting process
we need to report it to be able to get
that maintenance budget spent on those
pieces of equipment
before the property comes in lots of our
service areas if you look through the
budget thought
lots of our service areas in their
budget
do you have their own maintenance around
you
well i just kind of feel we're going
around around in the circle here and you
know but i mean i'm just making a point
there's no reason why places places
council of hamilton has made exactly the
same point
um but also the officers and david hayes
has made the fair point of why we've got
one overarching maintenance budget not
separate ones
i think if we were to have a maintenance
budget for the park
and it was set you don't have that
leeway to move things around
it's like almost like budgeting at home
wouldn't it you don't just budget for
wine said you've got your one pot of
money and you know how far that pot of
money has got to go and what it's gonna
cover
but
everybody's view is different
and next i have
councillor
possible honking fees yeah i was just
like this the same topic how's the
decision made um
to
replace the seniors maintenance
budget to replace equipment
and to just leave it out because in the
past they're trying to
it doesn't replace it they made it safe
by taking it away
so is it everything now being replaced
from the maintenance budget or
how is the distribution
whether it's replaced or taken away and
are we do people tell us when they're
going to remove it
i think adrian already answered that
question earlier as well if it's a piece
of equipment that can be repaired
it will be repaired from the maintenance
budget but if it's
non-repairable
then obviously
you can't
but it never used to be like that it
means to just take the swings out they
take everything off and then be like
well you haven't got any swings because
we can't
[Music]
i think that's what the importance of
this strategy is is helping us move
forward
the fact that we've got it now and it's
maybe it's being recognized as being
more important now than it was maybe
then i don't know but it's certainly
our driver too
i think that's shown that the play
strategy is
slowly working because things are being
faced yeah and i think in in the past i
think things probably have been replaced
so let's go back to that condition
certainly in 2019 but actually there was
work already being done since then but
it wasn't coming to us or to me to
report it and
update it on sheets like this to provide
us so it's just that communication i
think possibly this
hopefully
yeah i just want to go
to a point just
letting you all know
what happens
in covid
and the children have been knocked down
children that were used to being hunt
couldn't be hugged by grandparents etc
and what happens when they come out of
that and going back to school
we have a new a new park in mosul so
it's a good example
uh
to start with i'll be walking i'm down
there every day
i was watching children playing
and it was lovely to watch the fan
and they were playing quietly and over
the last few weeks
the noise level that's going up they're
playing together the joy you just keep
up the good work
because that's what we have to do
we don't want to allow
this generation new generation to
discover any more than necessary by this
horrible code
um
wow
anybody else have any questions for
adrian
and this is a picking up on the
discussion
um with president leather and curtis
lankford here rather makers budgets
i mean forecaster did decide because it
went through internal and with the
freshly decided external went through
internal they voted very narrowly
referred to full code stores full
council then decided and i can't
remember what the book was i think it
was like 23 8 or something like that the
maintenance budget so it's been decided
from full council is supreme so i accept
that
but always in life
and it applies to my business as well
you buy a nice shiny new piece of
equipment
and you love it but you hate it when it
gets to its mlp test and you find that
you've got to replace a suspension
you've got to replace this that and the
other and that's when it breaks down
between revenue and budget for the
revenue and capital of course you know
maintenance and capital of course this
is where the breakdown always happens
and and
we can pass them back between one and
the other and that's that that is very
easy um
to do
where there is this vision like we have
here and it doesn't apply just to our
just apparent so you see so many things
where you can fully build a hospital but
then you can't put the staff in i mean
it's incredible to see that happens
again and again and again all i'm trying
to do
in our thinking is to have these spaces
and we put what we can in with a
definite budget we know we can keep so
don't go buying expensive equipment that
requires them thousands from a revenue
budget you've got to go struggling
around the corner from because you've
got a grant from children in need to
spend a hundred thousand pounds that
you're still then gonna maintain it over
budget you haven't got afterwards and
that's the joy that i'm thinking i think
we need between
revenue budgets uh maintenance budgets
and capital budgets because i think
that's where we fall down between the
two
and
well hopefully on the 7th of december we
can
come together put our heads together and
shape our way forward
is
yeah okay any other questions for anyone
can i'm sorry
no no i just wanna i just wanna be clear
about this cheryl's mention
the endeavor is to repair something
that's broken
if something is so broken it's got to be
removed
will it necessarily be replaced or is
that when your your group your working
group make a decision
that to replace that piece of equipment
is going to be too expensive or
something or will it be replaced do you
see what i'm saying yeah
yeah i think that comes up i think
there's probably things that come into
consideration about which areas in which
park it's in um whether it's if it's
obviously if it's in an area that's
already
um demise that possibly a situation that
isn't being used anyway then it might
not get replaced but if it's if it is a
new area actually and it's something
that's been barely receiving it's broken
at all i
and that would come out if it's full
replacement that would come out of
maintenance
okay yeah just just to clarify i think
there is some yeah a little bit of
continuum there
we can't guarantee that if something
needs replacing it's going to
automatically be replaced and part of
what adrian and their team are doing is
an assessment of all the play areas and
that that's part of the the chart that
you've had
um
and and i think what members are saying
are right some of it
can't replace or if we can't leave it as
an open space we need to do those
assessments and i i think that's so
we've got quite a few parks in the
torrid area it's going to take some time
i think the assurance at the moment is
we are working on it um along with the
economic regeneration team along with
richard hayes team and the grounds
maintenance and i think then it's going
to be an assessment of what we do and
where
what the budget is and what we can do to
make the parks that we have got the best
possible spaces but
you know in terms of maintenance and all
that i think the difficulty with it is
it's really hard to predict
it's really hard to predict what may
break and when i mean you generally get
a good feel of when something is end of
life but we never know you know what
damage may be caused because that's the
other difficulty that we're faced with
is play equipment gets vandalized
so you know we can never guarantee that
you put something together it's
vandalized and we're going to be able to
replace that because that that's
additional problems so
it's all a big assessment i understand
you know what members are saying i think
everyone's point of view parks and play
areas are extremely important um but
it's kind of trying to make the best of
the resources that we have so
no i'm not going to guarantee that
something's taken out it's automatically
going to be replaced with that i don't
want to give members that expectation
but we certainly will always try our
best
[Music]
very good thank you thank you very much
um so i think we'll move on to item
number nine on the agenda now which is
the consideration of the forward plan
um
citizens advice were unavailable today
which um i don't think we would have had
sufficient time anyway to do the vote
because the strategy is obviously an
important piece of work
and it's been really informative um
listening to and talking to adrian here
about it
we did have a little chat
justice before the meeting was about to
start
and um cab are actually available for
january
um
so they may well be going into the
january slot
because that's actually a 6 pm slot and
if we are going to have a joint meeting
it's most probably better to be a
daytime one to have north devon and
ourselves together in the same room
but we're going to work on that and
firm the plan up as we go along
is there anything else
that anybody else would like to put on
the forward plan for by april may time
australia
you know i mentioned i mentioned it to
you
um the other week
about dentistry
yeah i'm i i'm advised really but
i'm
very very concerned about the lack of
dental availability
locally and i don't know if that would
come because i know we're talking about
here providers from health and their
health boards and things like that i
don't know if
dentistry could be discussed there or if
it should be a separate thing and who
are you getting to talk to us about it i
mean i would just really
like an overview of what the situation
is in here because i know people now
who cannot
get dental care for their children who
cannot register with a dentist it's
desperate but i don't know if that is
something that we as external could get
someone to talk to us about or not or
who to approach or what advice really
i think that will be dependent on who
comes in to talk to us
about
the health awards we haven't got anybody
actually confirmed who's coming yet but
we have thrown a few names around
um
that we want to contact that will be
able to give us an overarching view
of the whole of the health service which
to me includes dental treatment yeah
okay
so that wasn't a direct answer to a
question i know that
[Music]
um northern health care trusts
who are amalgamating with exiting them
that
somebody will be one of the speakers or
at least the information
on dental provisioning or then
no one then
is one of the key things we'd like to
find out
another run as private businesses now
these dentals but we must belong to a
trade body and somebody must be able to
come and answer questions
[Music]
25th the joint meetings experience
it says um
uh commissioners which is a clinical
commissioning awareness have you heard
anything from the community
commissioning group they can invite
their commissioners to commission both
dentistry and the healthcare services
and
so so are the commissioners part of this
meeting
on january 25th that depends on who we
can get hold of and who's going to come
uh had a brief chat um about doctor i
call it
coming and then obviously there's one
northern devon i've got an overview of
what's going on
so i think it's more of a case who we
can get to come
out of those who we invite
i mean obviously i'm flexible with
meetings if they if we need to change
the date
you know we can all work together and we
can do that but we will get
the relevant person here all the
relevant people
any ideas grateful
yeah another joint meeting we're not in
kevin but not in the freezing cold
office though
yeah and of course
pumping raw sewage
heavy rain beer is into
which is really nationally now
it's really raising its head more and
more as something people are not happy
to put up with anyone i do i think it's
terrible that
southwest water is still allowed to
sense the effect into the medicine scene
some of it raw sewage even in the
torridge on occasion yeah we can put
that in so that needs to be a joint one
really nice channel
they might not want to join ones with us
imagine
and if you know if it's a problem we'll
just go on and do ourselves well i mean
yeah i mean if you don't want to come
that september it is something that does
affect me because i think the january
one councillor
so then that might be two joint meetings
in a row i'm not uneasy
well we've got ca be in january then
we've got to help people then in march
and then we've got hopefully this
to deal with pumpkin
which could be the environment agency
southwest water an amalgamation of plato
i mean they need to send somebody
to a sport to do
okay anybody else any other comments
thank you all for coming and that's it